It's hard to imagine
but just 300 years ago,
it was widely believed that insects
spontaneously spawned
from dust, mud or rotten meat.
Their reproduction was felt to be
so strange and frightening,
they were known as
beasts of the devil.
It's partly thanks to the work
of naturalist and illustrator,
Maria Sibylla Merian,
that we can now find
this idea amusing.
Today Merian is celebrated as one
of the world's first ecologists.
She is admired by
Sir David Attenborough,
who described her as one of the most
significant contributors
to entomology,
the study of insects.
But she faced many challenges in her
journey to educate the world,
not least because of her sex.
Born into a family of artists
in Frankfurt in 1647,
Merian spent her childhood
collecting insects
and drawing them
in remarkable detail.
In 1665, she married
and soon had two daughters.
In an age where a woman's place
was thought to be in the home,
she defied convention,
publishing her first book,
New Book of Flowers, in 1675.
Merian was one
of the first to describe
the metamorphosis of insects
in detail,
declaring that all moths
and butterflies
hatch from eggs after reproduction
and do not just magically appear.
In 1699,
Merian, by then divorced,
sold her belongings and set sail
to Suriname in South America
with one of her daughters,
Dorothea.
She's thought to be the first woman
to travel in the name of science.
After a long sea journey,
they set off into the jungle,
battling through thick clouds
of black flies
that inflicted skin-ripping bites -
but it was worth it.
The jungles of Suriname were
a naturalists' paradise,
teeming with species that would
later be documented
in Merian's groundbreaking work,
'The Metamorphosis of the Insects
of Suriname', published in 1705.
Its stunning illustrations depicted
stages of development of Suriname's
veracious caterpillars
and vibrant butterflies,
as well as many other creatures
from this exotic habitat.
Uniquely for the time,
she also portrayed insects surrounded
by the plants they relied on,
revealing their relationship
to the wider ecosystem.
She was the first to show that the
change from caterpillar to butterfly
depended on a number of plants.
Though she had planned
to stay longer,
Merian's adventure
was cut short by illness
and after two years
she returned to Amsterdam.
Given the challenges of working in
a humid and unfamiliar environment,
it is remarkable how many species
she was able to observe
and catalogue in that time.
Her writing is also notable for
acknowledging the mistreatment
of enslaved indigenous
and African people
and their contribution
to her research.
She wrote in her description
of the peacock flower,
'The Indians, who are not treated
well by their Dutch masters,
use the seeds to abort
their children,
so that they will not become slaves
like themselves.'
Merian suffered a stroke in 1715
that left her unable to work.
She died two years later, aged 69.
However, Merian's legacy has endured.
To date, at least six plants,
nine butterflies, two bugs,
a spider and a lizard,
have been named after her.
Despite being over 300 years old,
her work on the biodiversity
of Suriname is still valued
by scientists
and could show us how some species
may adapt to climate change.